I deeply trust in my intuition.
- You're pregnant.
It's a food baby.
- I also practice manifestation and spell casting.
- Chris Evans, come to me.....
- And it is literal magic.
For example, last week.
- I've always wanted to work with Calvin Klein,
so I figure, why not take some photos, tag them on the 'gram, let the universe see that I'm here,
I'm queer, and I'm down to work with my favorite under...wear.
- [Yess...]
- And the next day Calvin Klein reached out.
So thank you to Calvin Klein for sponsoring today's video
and to the universe for working your magic, per usual.
I'm so excited to say that I speak my truth in my Calvin's.
And in thinking about my truth
I realized that one thing cats and I do not have in common.
Cats love boxes.
...I don't get it.
- One thing that people love to do is to put you in a box.
I mean, it's what the brain does right? Compartmentalize.
And though it's great for like neurons to categorize and differentiate information,
it is not so great for our artistic lives
And even if you're not an artist, I encourage you to listen to your gut
about the kinds of things you want to explore.
- Yeah, you know people joke about underwater basket-weaving, but
it's not a joke to me.
It's never been a joke to me.
- I have a reputation for doing a lot: acting, stand-up, music, writing, directing, illustration, poetry, stop-motion...
and I was worried that maybe my passion was a little all over the place
- She said I was a jack of all trades master of none, and it's really bothering me.
Like I'm just always, kind of like, gone after whatever seemed like really fun, you know?
Should I stop doing that? Would I be more successful if I just focused on one thing?
- You do know the full quote, right?
- What?
- Well the full quote is "Jack of all trades, master of none,
often times better than master of one."
So if you take the full thing in context, it's actually better to be a jack of all trades.
*scoff*
- ooOh
- And in stepping back and really thinking about it,
I realize that all of my exploration really boils down to one thing.
Ultimately, I see myself as someone who turns their pain into art,
and different mediums and platforms not only offer a variety of opportunities to do just that
but by constantly seeking new and challenging ways to express myself,
I feel more like myself.
I have a friend named Katie who inspired me so much in my early 20s.
Katie was always trying something new.
She trained with the circus, then she got her pilot license,
then she was doing burlesque dancing.
She taught herself how to knit,
dabbled in pottery, and the last time I talked to her
she was working with charities that helped exotic animals internationally,
so she got to pet tigers.
And though Katie did so many different weird, awesome things
that seemed super random, in the decade that I've known her,
I have never met anyone who is more authentically themselves,
and I think it's specifically because Katie does not hold back
with trying different things,
and with every new adventure she has,
the more centered she becomes in who she is.
So don't be afraid to explore your creative impulses,
to listen to your intuition about what excites you,
and to cast a spell every once in a while.
- Chris Evans, hear my call.
Chris Evans, let me pet your dog.
Dodger looks real cute though.
- Thank you so much to Calvin Klein for sponsoring today's video.
I speak my truth in my Calvin's.
I am a jack-of-all-trades.
I wore a bunch of Calvin Klein in today's video
including Calvin Klein Jeans and Calvin Klein underwear.
You can check out those and more styles on calvinklein.com
or by clicking the link in the description below.
I'm Anna Akana. See you next Thursday.